ist unser schulsystem kaputt jeder
fünfte 15-jährige hat extreme lese und
rechtschreibschwächen und die schule ist
für die meisten schüler einen ort des
grauens stand der neugierde was wir tun
können um die gesellschaft der zukunft
besser vorzubereiten
jetzt in klicks um zwei instant action
in einer der letzten folgen von klicks
und science fiction haben wir über die
besten methoden zum lernen gesprochen
das video kann bei vielen von euch
ziemlich gut an und wer das nochmal
sehen wollt hier oben ist der link und
natürlich in der video beschreibung nach
kurzer zeit ist dann eine interessante
diskussion über unser bildungssystem
entstanden in den kommentaren
viele von euch sind der meinung dass
kinder heutzutage nicht richtig auf das
leben vorbereitet werden und dass das
bildungssystem im allgemeinen überholt
und modernisiert werden muss und auch
die große debatte die durch den tweet
der schülerin ein ausgelöst wurde zeigt
dass viele menschen mit sorge auf die
schulen von heute blicken deswegen geht
es jetzt bei pixum um die probleme des
schulsystems denen wir uns stellen
müssen und die lösungen die die kinder
hoffentlich besser auf die anforderungen
der zukunft vorbereiten zuerst einmal
sollte uns einst bewusst sein
bildung ist das wichtigste gut unserer
gesellschaft wie wir unsere kinder
erziehen und ausbilden beeinflusst
maßgeblich wie unsere zukunft aussieht
wenn zum beispiel kreativität tatendrang
und innovation nicht gefördert oder noch
schlimmer zurückgehalten werden dann
werden die forscher und wissenschaftler
der zukunft nur nach schema f arbeiten
können und keine neuen erfindungen
hervorbringen heute müssen schüler einen
großteil ihrer energie auf das
auswendiglernen von inhalten verwenden
bulimie lernen nennt sich der
fachausdruck bei dem wir vor der prüfung
so viel stoff wie möglich in den kopf
stopfen damit wir am ende eine richtige
note kriegen nach der prüfung ist der
stoff bereits vergessen bevor der
unterricht zum nächsten thema übergeht
das hilft nicht nur nicht dabei wirklich
zu lernen sondern setzt junge menschen
auch noch unnötig unter druck und
starkem stress aus schließlich
entscheidet ein gutes abitur schon sehr
früh über viele karriereoptionen
unabhängig von den interessen der
schüler inhalte werden in der heutigen
digitalen welt immer unwichtiger in zehn
sekunden ist jeder historische fakten
googelt und jedes matter problem mit dem
smartphone gelöst die menschen von
morgen müssen kreativ probleme lösen die
computer noch nicht lösen können
schülern muss das lernen an sich bei
gebracht werden damit sie sich auf ihre
stärken konzentrieren können und sie
stoffe selbstständig bei
bringen können dabei spielt auch eine
wichtige rolle wie unsere heutigen
klassenräume aussehen
30 schüler hören einem lehrer zu der den
stoff des schul lehrplans durchbringen
muss die hälfte der klasse ist
gelangweilt und hat schon lange
verstanden worum es geht während die
andere hälfte total den faden verloren
hat trotzdem muss in der nächsten stunde
schon das nächste thema abgehandelt
werden es ist keine zeit da um sich um
jeden schüler einzeln zu kümmern aber
ist gerade das extrem wichtig der
lerneffekt ist das bestätigt eine studie
nach der anderen mit abstand am größten
wenn sich ein lehrer mit einem einzigen
schüler beschäftigen kann
dann nämlich weiß am besten wie viel
verstanden wurde
wo noch nachgebessert werden muss und wo
die stärken und interessen des schülers
liegen als resultat bezahlen eltern in
deutschland pro jahr durchschnittlich
profil 750 euro für private nachhilfe
denn nur die widmen sich dem kind
persönlich und individuell
der lehrer ist der mit abstand
wichtigste faktor für den lernerfolg der
schüler
da ist es umso trauriger dass die
menschen die die wissenschaftler und
ärzte der zukunft ausbilden kein höheres
ansehen in der gesellschaft genießen in
finnland ist das ganz anders doppel
kommt nur jeder zehnte bewerber den job
als lehrer und wird ganz schnell raus
geworfen wenn er sich nicht genug bemüht
und genießt einen sehr hohen status
dafür strengen sich die lehrer sehr
stark an erhalten ein viel höheres
gehalt und bekommen weniger schüler so
dass mehr zeit für jeden schüler da ist
als ergebnis ist finnland in den letzten
zehn jahren fast immer unter den top 3
der pisa studie in allen kategorien
ein weiteres problem ist dass des
technologischen fortschritts den citrix
video zu den gefahren von künstlicher
intelligenz spricht er an dass sehr
viele menschen schon in den nächsten
zehn jahren ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren
und durch computer ersetzt werden
chips statt grips heißt die devise in
der wirtschaft denn diese kosten einfach
weniger laut der studie die zukunft der
beschäftigung werden bald schon so viele
leute so schnell auf die straße gesetzt
dass der arbeitsmarkt nicht fähig ist
genügend andere arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen
buchhalter finanz gutachter und sogar r
und juristen werden bald feststellen
dass ihre ausbildung obsolet also
überflüssig ist
diese menschen sollten schon in der
schule darauf vorbereitet werden dass
sie auch kreativ und innovativ denken
können so wie es noch kein computer kann
solche menschen werden auch in der
zukunft noch gebraucht und eingestellt
das schema f erledigt der computer er
wird in zukunft zum beispiel im bereich
jura selbstständig die kommentare zu
paragrafen raussuchen und sich
vorbereiten können auf einen prozess
doch wie können wir all diese probleme
lösen
ein interessanter ansatz dafür ist ein
projekt nahm digitaler aristoteles so
wie einst der philosoph aristoteles
alexander dem großen alles beibrachte
was er wusste und auf die individuellen
stärken schwächen und fortschritte
seines schülers einging sondern
computerprogramm für jeden von uns das
gleiche tun schon heute steht uns eine
unmenge an lehrreichen videomaterial im
internet zur verfügung allein auf
youtube zb im simpl klappt oder der khan
academy befinden sich monate an
hochklassigen videomaterial das schülern
und erwachsenen beim lernen und
verstehen hilft der digitale aristoteles
würde mir ausgewählte videos zeigen mein
verständnis testen die effektivität von
videos mit anderen schülern vergleichen
und so für jeden schüler das optimale
lerntempo und die perfekten lernmethoden
finden schüler könnten viel aktiver
lernen wenn immer wieder fragen gestellt
werden denen sich die schüler nicht
durch das übliche weggucken entziehen
können dann denken sie viel aktiver über
das thema nach statt frontalunterricht
hätte der lehrer mehr zeit um projekte
und experimente vorzubereiten und sich
um die probleme und fragen jedes
einzelnen schülers zu kümmern
unser aristoteles könnte uns sogar unser
ganzes leben lang begleiten und uns
vorschläge zu interessanten und
wichtigen themen geben wenn wir bereit
dafür sind man lernt schließlich nie aus
und muss sich auch im job immer
weiterbilden
der digitale aristoteles ist keine
wunschvorstellung an diesem programm
wird gerade jetzt in dieser sekunde
gearbeitet polen einer der gründer von
microsoft arbeitet an diesem projekt
project aristo das programm sondern auf
intelligente weise mit dem schüler
sprechen können und sogar fragen im
sachzusammenhang verstehen und
selbstständig eine antwort für den
schüler aus dem internet suchen können
auch die khan academy benutzt viele
komplexe algorithmen die herausfinden
sollen wie gut verschiedene videos tests
und arten von fragestellungen
funktionieren und wie die besucher der
webseite am effektivsten lernen doch
nach all dem sollte man nicht vergessen
dass schulen nicht verschwinden werden
schon die erfindung von radio und
fernsehen hat damals viele leute glauben
lassen dass schule und lehrer bald der
vergangenheit angehören würden und nur
noch sehr wenige sehr gute lehrer alle
kinder unterrichten könnten doch radio
und fernsehen sind einbahnstraßen
niemand kann kontrollieren wie viel die
kinder bereits verstanden haben oder ob
sie überhaupt aufgepasst haben
im digitalen zeitalter ist das anders
trotzdem kann keine maschine
das bedürfnis für zwischenmenschliche
interaktion ersetzen wenn ihr mann an
alle eure erfahrungen erlebnisse eurer
schulzeit denkt dann wird schnell klar
dass die schule nicht nur aus dem
frontalunterricht besteht sondern auch
aus den gemeinsamen pausen mit freunden
dem sportunterricht schulausflügen
projekten oder vorträgen vor der klasse
technik alleine wird unser schulsystem
nicht revolutionieren aber sie kann in
einer krassen art und weise dabei helfen
schule spannender und effektiver zu
gestalten und wir müssen
schnellstmöglich etwas unternehmen damit
die gesellschaft der zukunft die
bestmögliche ausbildung erhält wenn er
mehr zum thema künstliche intelligenz
erfahren wollt und ob wir bald die
kontrolle über die roboter verlieren
könnten dann klickt jetzt hier oben zu
rap und zum blog geht es wie immer unten
und in der video beschreibung gibt es
weitere links aus dem video und
natürlich die die ich gerade genannt hat
und was meint ihr wie sieht eine
durchschnittliche schule im jahr 2050
aus gibt es überhaupt noch eine schreibt
es wie immer unten in den kommentaren
bis dann bleibt dran